o gol
eu e meu marido nós somos os caçadores
de bons exemplos
um casal de minas gerais que
definitivamente cansou de ouvir notícia
ruim
nós tínhamos vários questionamentos
dentro da gente com uma grande maioria
de vocês também tem quem é que nunca
parou para pensar qual é o verdadeiro
sentido da vida
tipo que eu estou fazendo aqui todo
mundo
uma hora ou outra pensou será que nós
estamos aqui apenas para comprar sapato
roupa carro casa namorar casar
constituir uma linda família constitui
um lindo patrimônio morrer e deixar uma
herança para os nossos filhos
só isso será que a gente está aqui
apenas para olhar para essa parte do
corpo umbigo e bolso ou será que a gente
está aqui pra subir um degrau e olhar
com o coração
viver em comum unidade fazer o bem e
ajudar o outro
bom esse era um questionamento
o outro era o mundo está acabando e
tanta notícia ruim que a gente vê que a
sensação que a gente tem é essa que está
acabando tráfico dependência química
crianças morrendo de fome doses sendo
maltratados terrorismo corrupção só isso
cara pelas pessoas boas bom
diante desses questionamentos
esse casal sabia que precisava de fazer
alguma coisa mas o que fazer e como
fazer
a gente não sabia porque são
questionamentos muito intensos
dentro da gente não é o saber o que
fazer
é mais complexo mas aí a gente viu esse
cara que lascou a nossa vida grande fala
seja mudança que você quer ver
mundo essa frase te traz a
responsabilidade porque é muito fácil a
gente culpa o outro né
a culpa é do governo a culpa da igreja
culpa da escola é do fulano ou ciclano a
gente não precisa de fazer nada mas essa
frase faz com que você deixe de ser
telespectador e queira ser personagem da
transformação bom continuar vamos sem
saber o que fazer e como fazer
aí nós decidimos tomar uma decisão nós
vendemos tudo o que a gente tinha
embarcamos numa viagem em busca de
pessoas que estão mudando o mundo
pessoas que pararam de olhar para o
próprio umbigo e que pensa no coletivo
a gente foi em busca de viver e conviver
com as pessoas que tiraram o bumbum do
sofá e botam a mão na massa para em
busca da solução e não dos problemas
botamos uma data 1º de janeiro de 2011
estamos até hoje na estrada mas quem são
esses bons exemplos que a gente encontra
neve vocês devem estar perguntando
porque bons exemplos são palavras fortes
às vezes a gente chegava nas ruas e
perguntava o que um bom exemplo pra você
e xixi aqui vocês não vão encontrar isso
não
algumas pessoas falavam outras vezes que
é um bom exemplo para você aí outras
pessoas falam assim amplo que como assim
engraçado como as coisas estão
invertidas nessa gente perguntar quem é
o traficante assaltante todo mundo sabe
mas um bom exemplo não
outras vezes a gente perguntava aqui um
bom exemplo pra você e as pessoas pa
madre teresa gandhi e mandela luther
king são francisco de assis cara mas
esses caras estão num nível muito alto
eu nunca vou ser uma maria tereza meu
marido nunca vai ser um grande vamos
baixar o livro um pouquinho né
não são pessoas não são seres que a
gente encontra todo momento né
agora aqui na sala por exemplo levanta a
mão pra mim tem algum professor
tem algum estudante tem algum empresário
são essas pessoas que a gente procura
pessoas comuns que não são santos e tem
o seu trabalho a sua família
suas qualidades e seus defeitos mas que
mesmo assim querem mudar a sociedade
onde vivem por exemplo esse cara tinha
um rocha
um dia ele era professor eric se tornará
educador
ele criou a escola debaixo do pé de
manga pedagogia da roda pedagogia do
brinquedo pedagogia do sabão 1700
tecnologias sociais
o centro popular de cultura e
desenvolvimento e ele nos ensina que
para educar uma criança é preciso de
toda uma aldeia rodrigo baggio um dia
estava fazendo planejamento da vida dele
como eu quero estar daqui dez anos mais
rico mais feliz aí dormiu e teve um
sonho onde ele vivia com em comunidades
pobres do brasil crianças tendo acesso à
internet e informática ele acordou e
decidiu criar o comitê de democratização
da informática e até hoje ele já
impactou 1 milhão e 600 mil jovens
alcione e os amigos do bem e decidiram
levar caminhões de alimentos roupas e
brinquedos para o sertão mas aí eles
perceberam que era pouco e precisavam
fazer mais
eles construíram casas de alvenaria
construíram escolas construir um ginásio
levaram cursos profissionalizantes
resumindo a história eles já conseguiram
quatro cidades do bem no sertão
agora o que vocês pensariam de um
criminoso
esse cara estava preso e um dia ele
lembrou que o sonho da vida dele era ter
piolho pra mãe dele catar piolho e fazer
um carinho na cabeça dele ele foi
lembrando de tudo de ruim que as pessoas
fizeram com ele e tudo de ruim que ele
fez com as pessoas
só que ela entendeu que ele era muito
inteligente só usava essa inteligência
para o mal
ele decidiu que a partir daquele momento
ele usar a inteligência para o bem
há 15 anos o cleves atende 120
cinco crianças na cidade de sorriso em
mato grosso
agora o que é pior do que um ser humano
pode ter na vida respondeu alguém perda
de um filho
agora imagina se a filha estuprada
assassinada e enterrada debaixo no
quintal da sua casa
essa deve ser a pior do ser humano pode
ter
essa mãe tinha todas as razões do mundo
para não fazer mais nada por ninguém
ela tinha sido violentada da forma mais
cruel mas ela entendeu que chorar e se
revoltar não ia trazer a filha dela de
volta
então ela decidiu transformar toda a dor
dela em amor para montar o movimento
maria cláudia pela paz bom nesses cinco
anos na estrada
nós conhecemos mais 1.150 bons exemplos
em nosso caminho ea gente percebe que se
o tião faz e nos ensina que para educar
uma criança precisa de toda uma aldeia
se o rodrigo deixou disse querer ser
mais rico para ser mais feliz se o
cláudio está usando toda é a
inteligência dele que ele tinha para o
mal para impactar a vida das crianças se
alcione nos prova que é possível
construir cidades
isso é cristina transforma toda a dor
dela em amor cara e eu e vocês e nós o
que nós estamos fazendo para mudar o
mundo conhecendo tantas histórias e
sabendo que são humanos não são santos e
que é possível cada um de nós mudar o
mundo responde a nossa segunda pergunta
que o mundo não está acabando com tanta
notícia ruim
muita gente boa fazendo coisas incríveis
por aí só não são divulgadas
então gente eu peço não estou pedindo
pra deus pedindo pra cada um de vocês
estamos assistindo hoje vamos falar mais
das boas ações
vamos divulgar mais esses bons exemplos
é possível a gente mudar o mundo falando
de coisa boa sim
não é aquela velha história que uma mão
da outra não precisa de ficar sabendo o
que uma mão da outra não tem que querer
nada em troca mas fica sabendo precisa a
gente precisa de divulgar esses bons
exemplos dos nossos jovens se inspirarem
e também mudaram o mundo ao seu redor
por quê sensibilizados com os problemas
do mundo todo mundo é a gente precisa de
divulgar quem está se mobilizando em
busca das soluções bom respondeu à
segunda pergunta mas a primeira pergunta
ainda estava dentro da gente qual o
sentido na vida
e aí a gente estava na amazônia um lugar
lindo visualizem floresta amazônica eo
tucuxis pulando sol nascendo eu fui pra
beira do rio fotografá lá fotografando
de repente eu sinto algo do meu lado o
olho é um garoto de uns 14 anos de
bermudinha sem camisa com uma toalha no
ombro sabonete na mão tipo voa que eu
quero tomar banho
aí eu olhei pra ele o pai babão
continuar fotografando nem de bola pra
ele decidiu puxar conversa ele apontou
para a barraca onde a gente mora vocês
moram ali eu moramos
aí ele fez a pergunta cruel que vocês
fazem nossos amigos não entende o nosso
trabalho a nossa família não entendia
ninguém que a gente contava entendia no
fundo no fundo nem nós entendíamos o
nosso trabalho
pensei esse garoto não vai entender
também vou resumir pra ele
nós somos um casal que cansou de ouvir a
notícia ruim vendemos tudo que a gente
embarcamos numa viagem em busca de
pessoas que mudam o mundo
aí a gente distribui essas informações
gratuitamente para outras pessoas se
inspirarem também mudaram o mundo ao seu
redor
ponto ele não entender mesmo né
santa ignorância e sequer olhou dentro
do meu olho e falou-se informação é o
bem mais precioso que o ser humano tem
se vocês distribui essa informação
também gratuitamente
então vocês distribui tesouro
eu nunca
eu nunca imaginei que alguém pudesse
resumir nossa história desse jeito aí eu
comecei desabei abracei ele ele me tirou
continuou olhando firmemente nos meus
olhos e disse eu não conheço ninguém tão
rico como vocês eu tinha acabado de
falar aquele garoto que a gente tinha
vendido tudo e fazer um trabalho
voluntário
ele não conhecia ninguém tão rico como
nossa a gente traz essa história
diariamente com a gente porque a gente
avalia todos os dias
qual é a riqueza que vale a pena na vida
da gente é só coisas quais são os
tesouros que cada um de nós estamos
distribuindo diariamente com o nosso
trabalho a nossa vida e com o nosso
presente
bom lá na amazônia foi respondida nossa
primeira pergunta o verdadeiro sentido
da vida é fazer sentido em outras vidas
não é só passar pela vida do outro é
passar e deixar uma marca e que essa
marca seja positiva sempre bom
identificando o que era o nosso trabalho
aí nós criamos alguns objetivos para ele
teve uma certa vez que a gente recebeu
um e mail que o assunto era obrigado por
salvar a minha vida eu achei que era
vírus mas a briga era o garoto que tinha
tentado suicídio três vezes e que
naquele final de semana ele decidiu que
ia morrer de todo jeito mas ele ficou
sabendo da nossa história e começou a
pesquisar todas as histórias que a gente
conta no nosso site
e aí ele decidiu na segunda-feira e não
se matar mais um ano e meio longo bonito
e no final ele colocou assim um dia vou
encontrá los e agradecê-los obrigado por
salvar a minha vida porque vocês me
devolveram a esperança no ser humano
eu lembro do fluence encara que a gente
fez nada
realmente as pessoas precisam saber que
o traficante ou assassino corrupto mas
elas precisam de saber quem são os bons
exemplos que estão ali do lado
então muda o olhar das pessoas fazer com
que elas olham lado luminoso do ser
humano se tornou o primeiro objetivo
o segundo é porque muita gente fala
assim ai queria tanto fazer alguma coisa
não sei o que é bom contando essas
histórias dos bons exemplos a gente que
é inspirar as pessoas a tiro bubu do
sofá e bota a mão na massa gente todo
mundo pode mudar o mundo
o terceiro nós estávamos conversando com
um dos médicos sem fronteiras e eles nos
disse ele nos disse sim missões se fazem
com os pés dos que vão os joelhos
daqueles que oram e com as mãos daqueles
que contribuem indicar é isso conectar
as pessoas que não pode fazer pode
ajudar financeiramente quem nunca
fazendo e o quarto
a gente estava saindo de um projeto
sensacional na bahia
e aí quando a gente estava saindo uma
das fundadoras começou a chorar e pá
bateu a mão na porta
é o que foi que aconteceu ela virou e
falou assim eu estou aqui hoje para
fechar o projeto porque brigo com
traficante para a criança está aqui eu
brigo com a minha família para eu estar
aqui eu cansei
aí eu abri a porta um casal falando que
não
o mundo inteiro tem pessoa igual a mim
eu não posso deixar vocês passarem dessa
porta sem antes prometeu pra vocês podem
voltar quando vocês quiserem que eu vou
continuar aqui que liga a alga que a
gente fez nada
nós simplesmente motivamos aquela mulher
valorizamos o trabalho dela se vocês não
podem pegar e fazer ou ajudar
financeiramente e maná energia positiva
gente valorizar e motivar todo mundo
pode se tornar os nossos quatro
objetivos com o nosso trabalho e nós
criamos algumas ferramentas uma grande
mobilização para a gente poder valorizar
esses bons exemplos que a gente tem no
mundo
nós escrevemos um livre a cada livro
vendido um livro doado e fizemos um
aplicativo com o objetivo de se tornar
uma rede social do bem onde todas as
pessoas podem buscar soluções porque
problema já tem muita gente falando mas
eu tenho uma outra ferramenta ea mais
poderosa de todas que eu quero pedir
para vocês agora
eu queria pedir todo mundo para levantar
e aí agora eu quero com toda força que
vocês têm dentro do coração de vocês que
vocês gritem eu show pode levantar a mão
bater a mão no peito popular o
importante é gritar bem forte no 3321
nós falamos que precisam na caçador de
bom exemplo nós precisamos de duas ações
a primeira tira a bunda da cadeira
todos vocês já tiraram ea segunda grita
eu show a mudança que eu quero ver no
mundo
vocês também fizeram isso e acabaram de
se comprometer conosco que vamos juntos
divulgar o bem
vamos ser todos os caçadores de bons
exemplos eu agora posso morrer meu
marido pode morrer porque foi com
certeza ficarão milhares de caçadores de
bons exemplos por aí ninguém de nós é
tão bom quanto todos nós juntos então
por favor vamos falar mais sobre as boas
notícias porém brigar